nach dem brand im flüchtlingslager von
moria schlafen die familien mit ihren
kindern noch immer auf der straße
es gibt nur noch eine hoffnung für sie
endlich runter kommt von der
griechischen insel
norbert röttgen fordert mittlerweile die
aufnahme von rund 5000 flüchtlinge hier
bei uns in deutschland
sie alle wollen nach deutschland
menschen aus dem flüchtlingslager moria
die nach dem brand in ihrem camp nun
wirklich alles verloren haben
12.000 geflüchtete lebten dort unter
menschenunwürdigen bedingungen des
mehrere feuer vor einigen tagen auch das
zerstört haben
nun leben sie auf den straßen schlafen
auf parkplätzen ganze familien haben
sich hier niedergelassen wenige haben
zählte die polizei hat die
zufahrtsstraßen zu dem lager abgeriegelt
die flüchtlinge dürfen nun nicht mehr in
die hauptstadt von lesbos am donnerstag
besuchten viele deutsche journalisten
die menschen das schiff hoffnung dass
das land vielleicht helfen könnte
die griechische regierung geht davon aus
dass die menschen das feuer in dem camp
selbst gelegt haben aus verzweiflung
über ihre situation und weil sie angst
vor einem corona ausbruch hatten diese
regierung hat nun aber scheinbar keinen
offiziellen plan was mit den
geflüchteten passieren soll
so lange müssen sie weiter auf den
straßen schlafen und davon träumen
endlich die insel verlassen zu können
und auf lesbos ist für uns bild-reporter
tippmann mir nun auch live zugeschaltet
sie haben gerade die bilder aus der
nacht gesehen es war bereits die dritte
nacht die die flüchtlinge jetzt auf der
straße verbringen müssten
wie sind die zustände jetzt am morgen ja
es ist recht apokalyptisch hier die
leute sammeln sich reste zusammen
irgendwelche bambus stöcker um sich
lager zu bauen
sie wissen nicht sie wissen nicht wo es
hingeht es wurde ihnen nichts gesagt sie
führen dich völlig im stich gelassen und
sie haben aber eine hoffnung und zeigt
euch das jetzt einmal kurz
hallo du hast gehört tatsächlich das ist
so wenn ich hier kommen und sagen ich
bin journalist aus deutschland das sagen
die leute
sie wollen zu mama merkel auch schon
eine million leute dort platz gefunden
und hier sind ja nur 500 die sind völlig
verzweifelt es sind viele kinder hier
und das ist wirklich eine sehr
schwierige lage hier ja uns haben jetzt
auch berichte hier in deutschland
erreicht das rechte und aggressive
anwohner auf lesbos jetzt verhindern
wollen dass eben endlos andere
hilfsgruppen zum camp kommen den
flüchtlingen helfen können was genau
passiert gerade
also die polizei die reihe polizei hat
hier die zufahrtsstraßen zu gemacht
damit diese leute hier nicht rankommen
also das ist auch eine art schutz für
die leute hier eine art schutz und es
ist so dass hier bestimmt 20
polizeibusse sind und gleichzeitig
passen die aber auch auf dass die leute
nicht von hier in die stadt kommt da ist
ja ein krone aus griff gab es gibt 30
infizierte und ein paar von denen sind
nicht auffindbar
gibt es denn jetzt überhaupt schon einen
plan wie es weitergehen soll das camp
ist ja fast komplett niedergebrannt
worden flüchtige können dort nicht hin
zurück wie soll es jetzt weitergehen
nach unseren informationen soll es ein
neues camp geben allerdings wurde das
offenbar den leuten hier noch nicht so
richtig gesagt weil ich habe sie gefragt
die wissen davon nichts
womöglich weil man angst hat dass sie
sich dagegen wehren werden
die regierung geht davon aus dass das
camp von den leuten hier selbst
angezündet wurde
und ich habe gestern leute gefragt ein
afghane sagte mir nein das waren die
faschisten also rechtsradikale griechen
die etwas gegen diese flüchtlinge haben
die geflüchteten die wegen krieg und aus
armuts gründen hierher gekommen sind und
die die syrer hier wiederum sagten das
waren die afghanen also ist es auch
etwas unterteilt hier zwischen den
ethnischen gruppen zwischen den syrern
den afghanen da gibt es auch afrikaner
die sich dann auch gegenseitig teilweise
nicht mögen weil es die harte
verteilungskämpfe sind vielen dank
silvia mann für uns auf lesbos
dankeschön mehr nachrichten und breaking
news nur bei bate schau dich hier das
nächste video an und vergiss nicht zu
abonnieren